like a little kid like we thank you
zip unzip I can see you buddy that's
very best yeah there you go
I mean with my mother over the holiday
are you filming
I am here with my mother over the
holidays hey you were very related I am
working with Netflix on this video to
show you guys how you can hook up your
parents with Netflix and to show how
easy it is for parents to register
themselves on Netflix it sounds easy
my mom has agreed to be the guinea pig
in this video to try to register a
Netflix account for herself live taped
on camera for you guys so you can see
just how easy it is it sounds so easy
you have confidence in yourself I do
that did something I confident oh now
Netflix is hooking my mother up with a
six month free subscription boom
the G is raised the wall Netflix has
given my mother a free six month
membership all she has to do is register
it for herself do you know what Netflix
and chill means neckflix and chill but
don't know what you mean when you say
what does it mean that that was my
question to you you know what Netflix
and chill means network movies in
television that's crazy Netflix and
chill do you know what that mean I do
not that's been enlightened be great
your iPad yes yes I swear that this is
my iPad we are screen capping why not my
under oath still so what you're gonna do
is you are going to download netflix
onto your iPad and for all of you out
there that think it's difficult watch
this
do you know how to download apps onto
your iPad do not oops okay that's okay
how did you get all this stuff on your
to begin with I have a man when on here
looks like it might have apps Oh an app
store an app store I've been there all
that to us yeah go ahead click that so
I'm gonna just type in netbook yeah wow
look at that it's so easy
okay now you sound a little inauthentic
alright now I would click that button
open I'm really sincere when I say this
is so easy okay
that's not better but look at this Wow
we're not done yet I was taking a time
to load so this time we can get to know
each other better as family because
Netflix brings the family closer
together how was your holiday oh now
we're worried look that could be us
lying on the couch like that but it
never is
nope what account right now if we wrench
into the the mix because of this car the
victory team we have to go to
netflix.com slash for Dean ok Congrats
you got a gift of Netflix so let's
create your account so my name mm-hmm I
would choose a password that you'll
remember let me just write this down so
that my mom doesn't forget her password
I never forget anything
how old am i 30 story checks out I'm at
least 18 years old are you at least 18
years old
yep dark now let's see what happens
welcome to Netflix you successfully
redeemed your gift your gift membership
will begin with a free month
now let's hit continue who will be
watching Netflix everyone your home can
enjoy suggestions so here what happens
is when you sign in for your Netflix you
can sign in under a certain name so it
will suggest things that are appropriate
to your different taste levels ah choose
three of these that you like from this
whole list though they're kind of
profiling me yeah making of a murderer
that sounds like it's right up your
alley
okay oh you like How I Met Your Mother
don't you no no attention okay and it's
now personalizing they're looking for TV
shows and movies that they think you'll
love this is like a Yenta of
entertainment and here's all the
suggestions for you get away orange is
the new black I have not watched that
one I think you guys would like a show
it's about women oh I see fragrance on
there yeah you want free energy it's
interesting for you all right I think it
was so easy here's the really cool thing
because Netflix sent you a Roku and they
sent you a six month free subscription
yeah noise they're gonna do that for one
of you guys out there we're giving away
yeah haha a Roku four and six months
free nestling little scription way but
now what we need to do is as a
mother-daughter team decide whether they
need to do to win this prize I think
they should be subscribed to my youtube
channel that's good I think that they
should leave a comment down below they
should leave a comment down which of the
comment be about should it be about
their favorite Netflix show it could be
about how much they loved - very much oh
my god for Christmas okay it's nice and
warm it's practical and functional and
then we want to leave them with is
information about the vest and not about
that so make sure that you are
subscribed to our YouTube channel leave
a comment down below complimenting my
mother on her Netflix abilities and her
vest with the hashtag cook up your
parents and hopefully you guys enjoy
Netflix with some family members
wouldn't that be nice wouldn't that be
nice did you have fun I did it wasn't
the worst thing in the world
and it was so easy to she said I don't
know you had it before so that's why you
had this cloud symbol so it means that
you downloaded it before to your cloud
and Ruth it wasn't me
oh did it I'll tell you know someone
else in this family it's downloaded to
someone else in this family but it
wasn't me
that's Gino shaggy that's his song that
he sings okay okay